I almost feel like I'm kind of the same
but the ground shifted beneath me you
know I didn't like radically change my
own positions but they've started to
mean different things I used to think I
was more liberal socially but I can't
say that now because what that means now
is you're Pro this radical trans agenda
and your pro-race essentialism I'm not
pro any of that it used to mean like I
don't know just an entirely different
field of things and I used to be more
Pro National Security and sort of the
National Security apparatus you know I'm
gen xer experience 911 on a personal
level
um
things have changed there too I
definitely the farther we get from 911
the less we need a lot of those tools
and the more I see them being abused my
feelings about uh federal law
enforcement agencies like the FBI have
changed as we've learned more
information so I I feel like
the world has shifted and my opinions of
it have changed accordingly but I remain
non-ideological
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the host of the Megan Kelly show Megyn
Kelly Megan I just said your name three
times that's four if I say Megan one
more time how are you I'm great how are
you good I realize that's quite an intro
if I say this is the host of the Megyn
Kelly show Megan Kelly and then I want
to say your name to bring you in yeah
it's a lot of Megan's a lot of maggots
okay
but I got you how you doing sister
what's going on I'm doing great all is
well I'm I'm excited this has been a
great news cycle it always makes me
happy and uh my kids are in a good place
now so that makes me happy too all is
well let's do the kids stuff first you
fled New York City you're in the suburbs
over there but you still are in the
tri-state area let's say uh are you
protected enough from the insanity just
by leaving Manhattan I'm yes I am and
I'm so excited I'm so thrilled we did it
you know we've talked about the
awfulness of the New York City private
schools before and how hardcore left
they went I mean hard core asking my
boys and they're all boys school
regularly if they were sure they were
still boys that school no longer refers
to boys as boys they call them your
student go collect your student they
don't say son
um this was one of the more traditional
schools in the city that's why we chose
it if we wanted far left we would have
gone to Dalton we chose one that was
more traditional but it went hardcore
and the thing about you know race
essentialism and in every classroom
where white children learn there's a
future killer cop I mean they went far
left so we pieced out of there pretty
quickly and we found this school in
Connecticut when we did our homework of
course
still boys and girls because I have two
boys and a girl and my boys school in
particular has been outstanding my
little guy says the pledge every day we
went to the annual dinner where they you
know say hello to all the parents just
the other day last week and the head of
school stood out there and said we are
unabashedly pro-american here and we do
not believe in equity of outcome we
believe in equality of opportunity and
we don't believe in teaching these boys
what to think we want to teach them how
to think like Dave you or I could have
written this as the ideal ethos for our
school and so I was I mean a single tier
I was running up God thank God uh our
goal girls school has been better than
where she was I wouldn't say it's quite
as great as the boys but we're working
on it
do you feel undue pressure when you send
your kids to a school I mean you're
Megan Kelly every administrator and
teacher and all the other parents
they're going to know who you are
they're going to know that if they over
step on something or if they have an odd
policy there's a good chance you're
going to talk about it that's got to be
a kind of delicate balance because you
also want to keep your kids private and
all that well I don't talk about what
schools we're at or even what city we're
in because I really have had some very
dark security issues in my past as an
anchor so just as a security measure I
don't do that and so I wouldn't be
embarrassing it would take a massive
fall down even even when I left the New
York City Schools I I haven't named them
I don't talk about them by name I don't
I'm not my goal is not to embarrass
anybody
um but if they cross the line far enough
I would have to it's definitely you know
an arrow in my quiver and hopefully they
won't necessitate it you know I I will
say like if something happened I've
become a squeaky wheel you know there
there was a memo that went out by one
teacher citing Kendy and anti-racist
this and I mean immediately I was on the
horn like what's this this and this
school was already on it they had
already taken care of it they were two
steps ahead of me so I knew I was in the
right place but
um I can't really worry about that and I
will say if I speak out publicly because
I for example my daughter's school they
were looking for a new head of school
and that we went to all the meetings and
I listened to every single candidate and
what she was saying on you know their
vision and I asked all the tough
questions about diversity Equity
inclusion the lovely name that doesn't
match up in practice
and I had so many parents come to me
after the fact saying thank you thank
you thank you thank you you know it's
like you know how it is when you're out
there like you're out there with your
opinions and so am I people are grateful
because they're still stuck on the other
side they don't feel like they can
especially touch those third rails and
so they feel really validated when they
hear somebody who's who can do so I I
can only imagine at like a school board
meeting how they're all staring at you
like Megan will do it we can just we
could just kind of sit back here she'll
she'll take care of it do you think your
politics have shifted at all in the last
couple years like I think you and I as
much as I can think of anyone in a
public sphere I think we're like pretty
darn close on things and whatever the
differences are it just doesn't matter
in terms of Being Human and friends
um but you know as things have spun out
of control over the last couple years do
you think you've shifted on certain
things
well I almost feel like I'm kind of the
same but the ground shifted beneath me
you know I didn't like radically change
my own positions but they've started to
mean different things I used to think I
was more liberal socially but I can't
say that now because what that means now
is you're Pro this radical trans agenda
and your pro-race essentialism I'm not
pro any of that it used to mean like I
don't know just an entirely different
field of things and I used to be more
Pro National Security and sort of the
National Security apparatus you know I'm
gen xer experience 911 on a personal
level
um
things have changed there too I
definitely think the farther we get from
911 the less we need a lot of those
tools and the more I see them being
abused my feelings about uh federal law
enforcement agencies like the FBI have
changed as we've learned more
information so I I feel like
the world has shifted and my opinions of
it have changed accordingly but I remain
non-ideological you know I'm at heart
I'm a soulless lawyer who wants to be
persuaded with facts if you come to me
with better facts instead of saying ah I
I was wrong I'll say hallelujah I've
learned something new I'm smarter today
than I was yesterday so I'm not
ideological I'm certainly not a
knee-jerk Republican or Democrat I'm
still a registered independent and
remain open-minded
does do you think that can work the the
independent thing like in sort of real
politic I know it can work for you
privately and personally but like that
in terms of just this craziness that
we're in it's either like we're gonna
usher in more of this woke stuff or
maybe we can stop it but the middle
thing is just again it's just getting
harder to hold in a way middle is not
the right word independent is different
Independence just I think not
ideological and open to calling BS on
both sides
um but I'll give you an example I went
to uh one of these like events where you
show up and you have deep conversations
and people buy a ticket to listen and
one of the guys who was there spoke near
when I did was Andrew yang and I like
Andrew Yang a lot I I don't agree with
him on most of his positions but he's
the kind of democrat I could get behind
Tulsi gabbard she's the kind of democrat
I could get behind
in no world do I ever see myself backing
somebody like Matt gates for president I
I you know I could never back somebody
like AOC Margaret Taylor green is not my
cup of tea you know so
I don't know you know if it were
Marjorie Taylor green versus Andrew Yang
I'd probably go with Andrew Yang you
know so that's what I mean like yeah it
could work for me I don't know if it's
going to work for the country but for my
own personal politics I'd be fine with
that if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about the
media instead of non-stop yelling check
out our media playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell